so Jane tell us what happens in the
movie
oh the one yeah
we just how much do I give away we
decide I love this movie so much we
decide the ending that we're gonna go to
Italy I know
um just always a good decision do I say
why
sure yeah sure okay I I I me what's my
character's name
believe it or not and so we decide to do
a bachelorette party in Italy and and so
it's it's our adventures in in Italy and
you know eventually our lovers our
husbands are whoever they are show up
and
and it's like why do we need them yeah
there's a lot of the hair that is us I
got to be with Andy Garcia for a few
minutes it was really fun for me yes he
had to kiss me too
I
can't wait to meet all the men here
oh yeah
wait okay
did you get to do anything besides work
when you're in Italy did you all to get
to do anything fun well I took Ted
Danson so that was fun and our dog
Arthur 17 and a half year old puppy dog
and
um he was and Todd kind of was
everybody's plus one he took us all out
to dinner and uh I mean the it's the the
food is just and and I she made me get
started on aperol spritzes which I don't
think I'd ever had in my life and then I
had to have one every night breaking my
rule of don't drink when you're working
Mary steenbergen that was out the window
yeah and it doesn't count when you're in
Italy Mary it didn't count and I had so
much fun and I have no regrets yeah yeah
you just say I'm going method that's
what you say in that in that environment
I should have thought of this this is
where my character is exactly
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
yeah
I'm going
everybody
[Music]